هو لا بد في النطاق الجغرافي عند النزول
من ايضا الحجاز بني حنيفه لانهم نزحوا من
الحجاز
ونزحوا بعوامل مختلفه لكن المؤرخون يشيرون
الى تتبع مواقع القطر يعني في ازمه حصلت
في تهامه عشان نقول هم جابوا من المدينه
ولجوا من مكه ولا من تهامه جبال الحجاب
الجبال الحجاز فانا الانتقالهم هنا ووصلوا
ايضا الى
الجديه عدم ومن الجديه ايضا اتجاههم هنا
الى الشرق وايضا الملقا ثم نزحوا ايضا
والى هذه المنطقه الواسعه المسماه بقارات
الحبى العباره عباره عن قاره هذا الجبل
الماثل امامنا احد ايضا القارات الموجوده
ولهذا كانت كان هنا النزول والاستقرار
اياما متعدده ثم نزوحهم الى حجر اليمامه
واستقرارهم هنا
[موسيقى]
اذا قارات الحبال نزلوا هنا عبيد بن ثعلب
الحنفي اكيد كان معهم خيام ما بنوا ولا
وكان في موارد مياه قديمه صحيح لكن لما
راح الراعي جنوبا واكتشف في قصور في حجر
اليمامه وحصون نزل ولهذا
الابار القديمه وايضا بعض الشعبان القديمه
تاتي هنا هنا من الجهه من الجهه الشرقيه
في المطار القديم والمطار القديم حتى
عباره عن اثار قديمه تعود الى الف سنه في
المنطقه كلها ملعقه ايضا بالاثار القديمه
[موسيقى]